digit of the ding-ding-ding-ding-ding
what's up thinking kind of throwing a
hat he's wearing a bowline branch and
branch this episode of Gina's dream
podcast brought to you by poland branch
similar to the hat Kermit swear and get
yourself laundry bedding for affordable
prices bowline branch is a wonderful
company they do a lot of great things
and they make amazing sheets so go to
Bowlin branch calm right now
that's blll and branch calm and enter
product code Jenna Julianne get yourself
20% off of your order it's also brought
to you by blue apron easy home-cooked
meals perfectly portioned out delivered
right to your door 40 minutes or less
each meal and under ten bucks each meal
guys this is the way to cook no more sad
takeout go to Bowlin branch sorry got a
blue eight blue and human ABS all yeah
inaudible yeah check it out guys go to
blue apron calm right now blue apron
calm / Jenna Julian and I get yourself
started with a couple of meals and see
how you like it
trust me I'm entreated me that they were
eating their belief in a per meal it was
so good were they watching the podcast
as well while they ate while they were
watching the twist stream I don't know
all they had your video in my video
going live no going live going live yeah
I uh I'm like definitely a person who
like if I'm eating something and I'm not
with a person like if I'm just kind of
by myself
I need something to watch like I need
something to watch I will not take a
bite
I could vouch for that that's true you
have to be watching like I'll just turn
on that books on my phone for like
thirty seconds why did you do when you
were a kid though did you always know
that that habit started in college so
you could eat in silence
I forgot how I learned how to do that in
college and I can't unlearn it
I know I feel like it's like a survival
skill when you're alone a lot that you
just learn how to make your own company
while you're eating it's probably true
it's probably true
yeah yeah so it was crazy windy last
night like windy is [ __ ] and yeah it's
so [ __ ] loud the world like might be
ending no don't say that
well it was really windy I feel like the
room
ending yeah there was an earthquake in
Japan you know [ __ ] up [ __ ] up man
what's going on um I want to play you
something that made me laugh for like 15
minutes yesterday scream love scream
laugh and cry you didn't even record it
or anything I didn't I didn't nope it's
probably the worst remix I have ever
heard
what's the caveat to find it oh no Jimmy
goes down Jenny goes down these deep
rabbit holes of Twitter like videos on
Twitter and like tweets and just dies
laughing yeah but now I don't know where
it is Kevin I found it
it just says terrible are you ready for
this I don't think they are who know
they could be by you mama don't get that
close
like why don't you find that I find in
common I find it funny I don't find it
like hey you see the way that they put
the audio files together they just put
them like on top of each other they
didn't even remix it they did nothing do
it the beginning kills me though that's
pretty horrible it's pretty freakin
horrible it was the best thing I've ever
heard
I would really was I was like scream
laughing for 20 minutes and crying I
know that you started like screaming at
one point I was like what's going on and
then you play that and I was like oh I
didn't you think that was funny is it
huh it's the funniest thing
I think I was screaming something like
this is the funniest thing I've ever
heard my life zooming that it's not the
funniest thing I've ever heard
it's probably not even in the thing
you've ever heard I don't know cuz
that's [ __ ] funny it's funny but it's
also just like alright I get it there
being [ __ ] guys get out of here get out
it Oh Kermit shame do I know what
there's there being bad we have a lot of
chords on the towards all the ground
chords on the ground we've got a lot of
chords on the grass this is why we don't
let you in the podcast room guys we're
actually we're going to Joshua Tree in
this afternoon we ought to be fun for
Julian's birthday Julian's during twenty
five on Sunday happy birthday happy
birthday - happy birthday - I and
birfday deal with war wars you are
terrific like a little bit they never
really had tomorrow or happy birthday oh
my gosh for you guys my birthday will
have been yesterday so don't even try
wish me happy birthday else man
I'm jerking peach you can't do that in
here
you got to get out peach you got to get
out hey Cheech out go goodbye listen to
this song and get out go so it's like
looking at me like wat Hank no go go on
this is a function I got this is an
absolute pressure I gotta make sure I
give credit here it says Gump Bott go
they tweeted at Joseph knuckles
these guys chuckles so uh yes we figured
we would we would have kind of a like a
chill out relax shoot the [ __ ] type
podcast this week maybe yeah cuz it's
your birthday and we're going to Joshua
Tree yeah mm-hmm never been in Joshua
Tree but gets windy is [ __ ] it's wieners
[ __ ] here which can only lead me to
think that it's like really windy out
there right blow away we're driving past
Coachella
which should be a nightmare which I'm
really hoping isn't too much of a
nightmare
guys Coachella is I I can't stress
enough how much it just doesn't appeal
to me like I am so far from someone who
would want to willingly go to a place
like Coachella I feel like when I die
and I'm in purgatory and I'm in this
cycle of like misery to figure out how
how I move on that purgatory is katachi
that is that is what would happen I like
I find so little about that that could
even come close to appealing and so much
about it that just irks me the people
the the everything I just I I feel like
I'm in a huge minority because everyone
and everyone and their mother I know is
your brother going do you think he is
yeah everyone I know I mean it could be
really fun
under the perfect circumstances like if
it didn't take you know up forever and
traffic to get there and back and you
have to do the hassle of parking or
camping or staying somewhere like if it
wasn't if it wasn't the sobering reality
of actually being a Coachella I thought
you were just there to have a good time
I'm sure it would be really fun so
unfortunately it's a little bit more
complicated than that and just the crowd
to people which I think I don't like
being big crowds if you were to able if
you were able to walk and do a
teleportation machine and just how the
poor took a joke right and there was
zero parking you go you teleport and
then when you're done you teleport back
and it was easy and maybe it was free
and all your friends with you and my
favorite bands are there I would still
never go ever I just feel like such the
minority I don't know everyone I talk to
I'm is like my it's the coolest thing
ever
how bad would it be though if we were in
a relationship and I was like begging
you to go to Coachella yeah that
wouldn't be our relation I would be
another wish Diane believe that you can
go to Coachella no Julia like I I don't
even feel like it's meet like it's not
even an age thing like I feel like
people older than me and very older than
me like want to go to Coachella I wanna
see colors no you're right it's just
it's a preference it's like if you spent
a lot of your time like a brother Marlon
I think goes to a fair amount of
concerts and Sonny loves them yeah if
you spend your time going to concerts
Coachella is like a dream it's like a
big giant concert where you see lots of
people
but with the amount of people of those
things alone will like forever drive me
away from them yeah yeah
how many retweets does that have not
many know that needs to blow up hmm blow
up and you know it like I'm sure there's
plenty of like dams like this that I
would enjoy seeing live you know how I
found this though so let's get Brian
Emmanuel on Twitter yeah and Vine he
makes like some really likes stuff dark
as [ __ ] but like some really funny stuff
it was in his likes because I was deep
down a rabbit hole of you getting the
deep like likes rabbit holes yeah if I
if I think somebody's funny or I like
them I will like I will go on their vine
I will find their likes on their vine I
will go on their Twitter I'm gonna be
their likes on their Twitter you find
some really funny [ __ ] by doing that
exactly because you don't you're in one
of those moods and you just want to
laugh but you can't really find anything
that's making you laugh go to someone
that you think is really funny and go
through their legs and you will [ __ ]
so good technique simply thank you it's
got a high success rate hopefully this
has 50 retweets and 76 likes right now
yeah I was in [ __ ] tears
it just is terrible is terrible
and I also found a place where you can
swim with baby otters yeah someone
tweeted that I mean yeah I know can we
please go it's like two hours from here
that'd be fun and Bo Burnham has um a
new stand up going on efflux make happy
yeah my body's [ __ ] ready
my body's ready and my boob hair hits
sorry about that might you know
sometimes like when you boo birds that's
my boo birds right now I totally know
what that's like and I'm sorry mm-hmm
thank you I know what it's like for you
and are you saying my boob hurts thank
you I know my boobs are really hurt eel
ate Li 30 Hardy mm-hmm so you
we're going to drive show tunes we're
driving past the Coachella Valley which
means we're hopefully not going to have
too much traffic and where we're going
out to like that desert the high desert
we're going to like a little house
renting it for the weekend and we're
going to share Bibi we're going to just
hang out and like really just be
secluded which I'm excited for because
Palm Springs is like it's almost like
that but this is even further out so
it's like less civilization less human
beings well cuz I got Julian the drone
for his birthday though the only thing
that he wanted and you've been having a
lot of fun with it around here but hello
space right yeah the more like remote
the space the easier it is to just get
away with freely flying your drone yeah
sounds like let's go somewhere because
we've always wanted to go to Joshua Tree
it's ever been a good time yeah I was
like let's go to [ __ ] Joshua Tree
let's just do it we didn't really plan
it which is why we haven't left yet
we're still here yeah um let's just go
let's just go and fly your [ __ ] drone
and get some nice Star time-lapses for
your birthday because that's literally
all Julian wanted today that is all I
want to do and I appreciate so much that
you've indulged in that but like think
about this really quick my birthday like
the day of the year that I get to do
kind of whatever I want or that I want
to make myself the happiest I want to go
out to the high desert where there's no
human being right that's my that's my
paradise and like it's almost the polar
opposite of something like a child even
though it's like maybe 20 miles over
sure it's so close I'm like nervous I
really don't want to hit crazy traffic
I'm like such a geezer listen to me I
hate I hate all those young kids get off
the rails that was the first thing that
came to my mind as well listen to this
[ __ ] loser maybe in Syria thank you
guys like my babies no wait he's a
teaser um for my birthday I just wanted
to lay on the couch and eat veggie girl
and play elderscrolls for your birthday
I was so I was like so hell-bent on
taking you I was like I want to take you
out to a nice dinner get your shoes on
let's go get some nice wine and dinner
and you
like I really just want to sit here like
well your birthday your call and like we
ordered veggie grill and just have a
super relaxed day but it's like that's
what I appreciate about us and our
relationship and like just being honest
because like there's no need to like
front I want to go to the desert and
look at the sky okay and you want to
watch TV and eat takeout no I wanted to
play Elder Scrolls were you want Elder
Scrolls that they know so hard I was
also playing that game on my iPad to be
like I don't know why am I remember a
server one of those taps I was the one
you hated but you played all the time
god money um hopefully you guys forgive
us if this is a rather short podcast
this week it's been a crazy week and
we're also trying to have this weekend
happen really quick we're going to take
a short break and shout out to our
sponsors so we'll be right back
or will we right now we'll be right back
you bet this week's podcast is brought
to you by bowl and branch bowl and
branch is the first honest and
transparent betting company a startup
founded in early 2014 I use only
sustainable and responsible methods of
sourcing and manufacturing and they
donate a portion of every sale to
charity to help fight human trafficking
while preserving fair prices for you
guys the customers they don't just make
great sheets there are a great company -
something that is quite unusual in the
textile industry but let us tell you
their bedding is quite comfortable they
have bedding sheets towels blankets
duvet covers and you can go to Boleyn
Bridge calm today for 20% off your
entire order everything and you get free
shipping as well then they have hats
Kermit's wearing their hat right now and
they have hats permanence is currently
wearing that hat one more thing guys
about Boleyn branch they will let you
try out their cheats for 30 nights
risk-free if you don't absolutely love
them you can send them back you
they have nothing to lose go to Boland
branch calm that's bol au and branch
calm today for 20% of your order use
promo code Jenna Dewan that's full and
branch bol L and branch calm promo code
Jenna Julian and get yourself some nice
wonderful bedding today this episode is
also brought to you by blue apron guys
it's cooking made easy it's so
frustrating to go to the grocery store
having to pick out ingredients having to
measure everything blue apron does all
that for you have you covered guys for
less than $10 a meal blue apron delivers
all the fresh ingredients you need to
create home-cooked meals just follow the
easy step-by-step instructions they
include each meal can be prepared in 40
minutes or less no overwhelming trips to
the grocery store no more sad takeout
with regret at the end set just to give
you a quick idea of what kind of stuff
they're cooking up here's a little peek
at this week's menu for blue apron
you got ricotta pesto almond and arugula
pizza with asparagus ooh that sounds
good
almond and fresh pasta with mushroom and
ramps next asparagus and leeks spring
quiche with a real salad they also have
vegetarian options they have all sorts
of options to fit your dietary needs
guys new apron has you covered check it
out right now guys get yourself some
wonderful delicious and easy to cook
meals go to beYOU apron comm slash Jenna
Julianne that's blue apron comm slash
Jenna julienne blade a better way to
cook alright guys thanks for hanging out
for that I welcome back we're gonna play
you back in now
on the back bench is not this is not I
see music oh no hmm this will not become
our theme music my god
like whoever made that I want to hire
you to just make music for life there
you know what the thing is you don't
even need to they're going to follow
their calling
I feel like robot um also this week
something fun that we did is you job
music video and we had a photo shoot
that was your first photo shoot ever
it was my first photo shoot ever which
was very interesting I mean I had been
at photo shoots before but I've never
been the subject of one yeah did you
have fun
except for my college roommate wanted to
photograph fish on the ground there but
I had fun I had a lot of fun I think it
was a combination of Robin being an
absolute angel being with you doing it
and also having the dogs there like it
was a trio of brilliant and fun and
Happiness and like those pictures came
out so great yeah I I had zero
professional pictures ever and so to go
from that to like such a cool thing I
feel like I've been spoiled so now every
photo should I do after this I'm gonna
heat spoil yeah but yeah we got some
really cool pictures uh we did family
pictures with all of us and then it's a
fun dog pictures really that was cool
really fun huh it's fun mm-hmm and how
is shooting legendary for Josh it was
good you guys had a lot of fun we did we
had a lot of fun we we had no like no
real script structure plan we you know
how we had ideas we had like an idea for
the video but we didn't have we ever
didn't go anywhere for scouting or
anything we just kind of did it so we
went out at 9:00 p.m. and figured it out
and got done at like 1:30 and that was
it and how did you do that shot with the
drone like drops into the parking garage
yeah so we found this parking garage and
like the opening job yeah the opening
shot which I love that shot but we so
the entire parking garage in the parking
lot adjacent to it we used for a lot of
the video so the idea was if we're going
to try to do this drone shot which I
immediately wanted to do and I saw how
it was like an upwards tunnel I was like
this would look so cool
I was like we need to do that last
because it's going to be loud and we
might get kicked out so let's get all
the other shots done first and so we did
and then we really alright time time to
try to do this drone shot put the drone
up in the air we do it once a little
shaky I'm like we can do it better we do
it again and I feel like we gotta got it
and then we land the drone and nothing
happens like no one comes up to us we're
right across the street from Paramount
Pictures by the way like where the
security booth is up and running and we
have a drone up in the air Paramount
Pictures like think of a worse place to
be next to when you're illegally not
illegally but just not permit filming or
whatever and I gotta go to Josh's dream
and get out of here and then we just not
know whenever said anything so we kept
firing the drone we did more drone shots
and you know but for that yeah for that
shot I really just I flew as high up as
I could while maintaining a good like
view of things enjoyed it so you were
standing in the I was yeah so I was so
drought you could see Josh but I was
like behind the pillar so you can see me
the show you weren't like up at the top
and then oh no I was looking at the
screen of the drone of all time I
couldn't even see the real drone which
is kind of nerve-racking not to be able
but you were down with Josh I was down
with him so I I was next to him and I
flew it all the way up into the sky
which was I tried to Center it and then
I started to lower it but I had to make
sure I was lowering it directly down the
center otherwise it would scrape the
side or it wouldn't have a good shot but
yeah I was I was exciting that was an
exciting she's did it on him yeah really
close it's funny because you can't get
it to closest and without the wind
blowing their hair and then you're like
okay I know there's a drone there now
helicopter yollop ah Kalibak that's what
Julian used to call motorcycles the Muse
little yeah be in the backseat of my car
my car when I was little I was five no
my mom would be driving us around and I
would just be like in my car seat or
whatever and and it would be like I'd be
like good no that's the sound I would
make with my baby mouth good here we go
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah do
it oh yeah yeah yeah thank you
oh yeah I used to say helicopter how
Epoque door and flutter buddies flutter
buddies and flutter buddies is something
that I feel like we should adopt us as a
culture and icicle broccoli trees trees
yeah well you're not wrong
yeah wall trees a little trees trees and
cheese fries and cheese trees and cheese
what are we gonna eat this weekend
Julian has already made it very clear
that we need to get stuff to make
grilled cheese and Bloody Marys
and Bloody Marys whoa are you eating
cheese now no vegan grilled cheese oh I
didn't have cheese except for when your
brothers in town I had something that
day but I made myself a vegan grilled
cheese the other day and it was really
good but the problem is like for vegan
grilled cheese you need the right cheese
not you can't you can't just use that
yeah so we're gonna get some vegan
cheese some bread yeah when we go to
Gelson's we get this thing called nut
cheese I'm sure it's a brand you know I
don't exactly comes in like a paper
wrapping like brown paper wrapping [ __ ]
so good but if you they make a pepper
jack one and a cheddar one and you put
them together on a grilled cheese and
it's like the perfect Oh Julia [ __ ] I
got to Julian
grilled cheese vegan grilled cheese am i
right Kichi I don't remember telling you
to come back in here
um and then some Earth Balance right
uh yeah Earth Balance and they get the
right bread and yeah that's the thing
though is that it's difficult eat I
don't think that there is a vegan
gluten-free bread that exists is there
there are yeah some of them have eggs
but if you find the there's a couple
that have no eggs in the bread but is it
like vegan gluten-free is one of the
toughest combination of diet because if
you're gluten-free like if you're celiac
and you're trying to find like a vegan
meal or some sort of process pre-meeting
it always has weed it always you see me
tea grabbing my hand on a scratchy Oh
him you at him you're a vegan here yeah
like if we're eating out though like
somewhere favorite restaurants although
you remember gracias Madre that
restaurant the Mexican restaurant that I
had first ordered from when you were in
Galan Berg mmm they are one of the only
places where Julian has called and
everything is not only vegan but also
also gluten-free which is which is rare
but I feel like it's starting to happen
more and more like why well I mean if
you're catering to specialized diets why
not just [ __ ] be like oh we got some
bread ready I agree it makes sense it
really does and it makes it a lot easier
but it's frustrating when like like uh
if it were up to me oh [ __ ]
if we're up to me I wouldn't be a
hundred percent gluten free you know
like yeah sort of would eat gluten I
would I wouldn't eat a lot but I
definitely wouldn't be like zero gluten
ever you know and like I'm choosing to
eat more vegan or plant-based or
whatever so it'd be nice if I could have
both but yeah sometimes it's tough but
this weekend it won't be tough because
we're gonna have everything right
everything what else do you want to eat
for your birthday and besides grilled
cheese and Bloody Marys grilled cheese
mac and cheese
well not sushi cuz we're going out there
to the desert that wouldn't make sense
nasty is grilled cheese mac and cheese
is that it I think something to eat for
like two days no okay maybe some chips
okay chips okay we can do that I
personally like when you drink Bloody
Marys
I don't know how you can drink like more
than one bloody no I can only have two
it's kinda gross after a while okay
after a while but easy with the word
gross it's a good drink I have like two
pretty damn big ones and then I'm like
alright I need something else yeah
because I need this like if I want a
Bloody Mary it's because I'm craving the
salt I'm craving the flavors I don't
just want the alcohol so it's more of
like a you know like a taste experience
as well as like a drink and so like one
big one and then I'll make another one
and I'll be like ok that's enough acid
that's enough salt I'm good let's move
on but those two Bloody Mary's it's like
perfect ass in asset I stopped playing
bass what even is this time count it's
for your birthday that part kills me
alright that's a lot of suck um little
did you know though for your birthday as
a surprise I told you we are going to
Joshua Tree but we're actually going to
Coachella listen I got two tickets
they're like $7,000 a piece but we're
doing it Jillian yes you were this it's
your dream and we're going are you
excited new one I just imagine you like
walking into the room and being in full
clothes and
living all them off like a little shitty
Coachella a bit like we're going to pay
all ready have my temper you're like
you're bending god Mach would crush
Coachella mark would be people every day
give you hundred mock in a crowd be like
don't touch me do it just act like
you're lucky Coachella please for one
second I don't know who you're talking
about
oh all right got it all right all right
fine all right what's the situation that
mocks in your like standing in a crowd
watching somebody and people won't stop
dancing into you um okay um such should
just be like really angry you're mad at
people for bumping into you the only
thing worse on this planet then you is
your stupid frickin dance moves why are
you covering your face I don't know I'm
not covering my face get that [ __ ]
alright wait I gave Harry Styles oh yeah
I add two names I had it with me right
now I just I'm not mom
um but yeah so we're going to Coachella
whew birthday I hope you're pump
I am Julien we're gonna we're gonna do
all of the things that you want to do in
terms of eating cheese we're just gonna
do it at Coachella it's not what I want
to do if I'm at hotel I won't eat a
single calorie I'll be so tense I'll be
like marbles in the car
I won't eat anything I'll bury my food
I'll go out underneath the stage I'll
dig a hole and I'll bury all that cheese
mm-hmm okay I'm like I'm very
animalistic in that way I never if I'm
not comfortable with my environment I
don't feel safe I will not eat a single
bite of food I did a lot of people early
does need a real MVP guys who are like
that also like girls girls will get made
fun of I don't know why I'm limiting
that to gender a lot of people get made
fun of for maybe not like eating what
you normally eat League on a first date
or like
if you're in a meeting or something you
know sort of nibble a little bit
someone's like aren't you gonna eat more
than that because you're kind of not
really comfortable to just sit there and
start oh yeah like I'm kind of
uncomfortably I'm a little nervous I'm
not just gonna shove food in my face
dude all house three pizzas in a row in
the dark at home no one can see me
that's when I go crazy but well yeah
when I'm around other people I don't
feel exactly comfortable or safe or you
know maybe just adjusted yet to that
environment
I'm not little food in your mouth yeah
so Katella I probably would just
projectile vomit on people but do the
observation oh stop stop no you're not
playing this anymore we're done I swear
Oh Julie my name is Julian Jill you're
ruining the fun Joshua Tree coach al hey
guys if you want to go back in time go
visit a Joshua Tree will be the last
weekend you like that one
yeah those good knows good don't play it
if she plays it I'm not
oh no it's bothering it was stuck it's
up you know what I just decided what
this week we're gonna have Coachella as
the background on the podcast you're a
troll we are it's good you guys have our
Guinness II know this man with that
[ __ ] ferris wheel or whatever oh do
they just move that in there for
Coachella that giant Ferris wheel is it
a real ferris wheel I'll [ __ ] no no
yes of course it's in everyone's picture
from Coachella but that's not there most
of the time no it's a blank empty valley
they move everything in for that thing
that's Dave that's Carney [ __ ] is Carney
a derogatory term
what's Carney like carnival why would
that be derogatory because sometimes
people call people that work at
carnivals carnies and that's kind of
derogatory that's that mean I'm joking
no yeah I don't think it's like just
describing
that being there as Carney is well is it
fair to call a broken down and rebuilt
ferris wheel at Coachella Carney because
that's kind of hard I think it's correct
it's the definition of Carney it's a
carnival
thanks Cory I think it's corny Oh
shots fired no I was a perfect time to
play
you're not playing that anymore you were
you heard the last of terrible you guys
we we're going to be sure to document
this weekend you know I'm going to film
some hopefully cool stuff with the drone
and everything out in the desert and
we're gonna have this a nice family
relaxing weekend and my birthday yeah
I'm very grateful I'm very grateful for
you taking me out there it means a lot
you know you you're driving them I know
I'm time I also am very grateful for all
of you guys I've already started to get
birthday wishes but I mean just in
general I appreciate all of you guys
yeah being part of our lives and
supporting us and listening to us and
watching what we make and caring means a
lot means a damn lot thank you for cute
guys I just you make me feel like I'm on
top of the world as if I was at the top
of the Coachella spin thing that the
carnie what is it the ferris wheel I
feel like I'm at the top like a child
ferris wheel with you guys like it
really just yeah weird I mean if only we
had a song really good play right now
all right fine you want to play seven
all my time oh my god all right she'll
play us out with this guys make sure you
check out our sponsors everything's in
the description below blue apron polar
Branch great stuff please go check it
out it makes the show free for you guys
we appreciate it you guys have been
awesome and we hope you have a wonderful
weekend we'll see last weekend in in
Joshua Tree I lost it
well you know sometimes okay
I found it bye guys this is this is
playing over the dink song right now
no that's what happened no I I don't
have control over okay we good bye guys
baby yeah